- We live in a universe
where statistically
disorder is king.
As time moves forward,
things fall apart.
Stars burn out.
Energy spreads out.
Entropy conquers all.
But humans, life, fights
that trend.
We build things.
We organize things.
We add information.
So why is that we love
destroying things?
[shouts]
Exploding fireworks.
Fights and crashes.
Even popping bubble wrap.
Ugh!
Tiny cute things can make us
want to just squeeze 'em
to death.
Ugh!
Why?
[electronic music]
♪ ♪
The power to destroy
is a delicious one.
Even just holding this here,
knowing I can drop it,
I am in control.
I can exert my will in a
dramatic and irreversible way.
Ready?
Ready.
♪ ♪
Ugh.
[laughs]
Beautiful.
Why does that feel so good
to do,
or even just watch?
For me, throwing it to its death
was almost relaxing,
like I feel calmer now
after being destructive,
like I've vented
some pent-up energy.
Or anger?
Why do we like breakings things
when we're angry?
There's a growing trend
of businesses
anger rooms that are popping up
in places
like Texas and Toronto.
People pay to visit
these anger rooms
and let off steam by smashing
mock-ups of workplaces,
kitchens, and more.
Catharsis Theory proposes
that such acts of destruction
reduce our anger.
But do they?
Sometimes, but sometimes
they don't.
This is what makes studying
the mind so difficult.
Researchers are still looking
into the specifics
and the variables involved,
and I want to see firsthand
and in person what it's like
when people get angry
and then break things.
Will then be more or less
violent afterwards?
To demonstrate
Catharsis Theory,
we set up our own anger room
to see whether or not breaking
things will help calm down
some angry people.
Our subjects think
they're participating
in a study about opposing
political views,
so we've asked them to write
an essay
on different polarizing topics.
- Come in.
- Kashona? Hi.
How are you?
I'm Michael.
- Hi, Michael.
- It's nice to meet you.
I was just with your
co-participant Clint.
He's in another room.
I'm gonna give your essay
to Clint,
and he's gonna critique it,
and you're going
to critique his.
- Okay, thank you.
- See you soon.
- He wrote a lot.
I didn't write that much.
Okay.
- Each of our subjects
has been paired with a man
named Clint,
and they will be critiquing
each other's essays.
- "Police officers have
a very difficult job.
They have to protect us mainly
from people of color."
[laughs]
- The thing is...
Okay, here we go.
I'm actually Clint.
"Overblown, un-American.
Get over it."
My job--
or rather, Clint's job--
is to make our subjects mad
so they can test
our anger room.
"You should be ashamed."
- "You deserve what's coming
to you."
What a asshole.
Ha.
Changed it to black.
That's better.
Oops.
- Okay, Kashona.
I'm back.
And you were with Clint.
Okay.
- Mm-hmm.
- Let's go through what he wrote
just quickly.
- He wrote--
- Did I put that that way?
- No, you didn't.
- Did you turn it around?
- I did turn it around.
He seems like a bigot
or somebody.
I didn't want to keep looking
at his face.
- He's responded to
your essay there.
- We can't tell people where
to go to eat for lunch,
what car to drive;
like, that just really
irritates me.
- This is a person that is
making arguments
that are not based in
any fact.
- He's clearly someone
who thinks
that the people who are on
social programs
are lazy.
- I was like,
"What the [bleep]?"
- Getting fired up, mother--
ooh, I'm getting fired up.
- It's disgusting.
- I got an F-plus?
Oh, I hope I don't see him
in the hallway.
He's a dick,
and that is why he is part
of the reason
why our country [bleep] sucks
right now.
Because he's stupid.
- Well, I think that
was pretty effective.
We've got a lot of angry people
on our hands,
so will demolishing things
calm them down
or will acts of destruction
throw fuel on the fire?
[dramatic music]
Let's explore Catharsis Theory
with an expert.
- The modern view of catharsis
is that by acting out
we release sort of like
a pressure valve
and that releases that energy
in order for us to sort of
build up again
and handle everyday distress.
- People who are angry
and aggressive
who then act that out, what
would they feel afterwards?
- What many studies have found
is that it's a short-lived
release,
and it feels good--it feels
really good to release--
but what happens
in the brain is,
the brain enjoys that.
There's really a reward to
build up that pressure again
and then release it again.
It's a temporary fix,
as far as we know.
- I didn't realize
it was so complicated
and still being researched.
I thought it was
black and white.
It was--you do this,
and you release the emotion
and it's gone.
- Yeah, not as much.
We don't have this
perfect definition
of catharsis,
where everybody agrees,
here's how it works,
here's how it ends up.
- Well, let's see if catharsis
works for us.
♪ ♪
Now that Clint has sufficiently
angered all of our subjects...
- He's more like a [bleep]
pussy, as far as I'm concerned.
- It's time to put
Catharsis Theory to the test.
♪ ♪
Some subjects will be allowed
to actively take out
their anger
on all of these beautiful
art objects.
You have completely free reign
to break anything in this room.
- What?
- Okay?
Other subjects are instructed
to sit in the room passively.
I want you to reflect on
the essay, the arguments,
the critiques,
and also on the objects
in this room.
- Am I going to meet Clint
or not?
- No, you are not.
- Okay.
- That's not part of this study.
- Okay, got you.
- Wil these subjects
feel less angry
after their violent acts
of destruction?
Only one way to find out.
[rock music]
♪ ♪
[elevator music]
[rock music]
When we are angry,
the body's adrenal glands
release cortisol
and adrenaline,
readying the body and mind
for fight mode.
- But Catharsis Theory
hypothesizes
that letting it out relieves
feelings of aggression.
[elevator music]
[crack]
[rock music]
♪ ♪
Will these subjects feel less
angry after their violent acts
of destruction?
- Okay, I'm done.
- Before we move on
to the final step
of our anger room
demonstration,
maybe we can gain insight
from someone who makes
a living by hitting.
Not objects but other people.
Mark Smith, aka "Rhino,"
is a champion bodybuilder,
boxer,
and UK gladiator
who knows a thing or two
about how to destroy
an opponent.
♪ ♪
So when you're going into
a fight,
you know that you're going
to get hurt.
- Yes.
- You know that you're going
hurt someone else.
How do you psych yourself up
to be good at that?
- When you get into a fight,
you want to stick to
your game plan,
stay focused, and be relaxed.
- Relaxed.
Because I would have thought
you'd want to go in angry.
- No, because if you go in
too angry,
all you're doing is...
and you're not thinking
straight,
it turns into, like,
a school brawl.
It's a very tactical game.
- Right.
- The eye of the tiger,
like Rocky.
- But this is fascinating to me,
because you would think that to
physically outfight someone,
in nature, we would have evolved
to run off of angry and fear.
- That's like two lions;
I agree with you there.
Two lions attack and go
full out, don't they?
There's no pace in that fight
whatsoever,
like animals, but you have to
know when to be an animal
and at what point in the fight.
Bang!
- Oh!
- But, like--so it's point in--
- I'm a very jumpy,
flinchy person.
- It's knowing when to pull
the trigger.
- If you ever find yourself
angry in your real life,
do you find it helpful to punch
a punching bag...
- Definitely.
- Yeah?
I will get angry, like,
I'm on the phone
with my bank, and I might think
slamming a door
or just hanging up and throwing
my phone on the bed--
- No, don't throw your phone,
and don't slam doors.
- Why?
- Just come and exercise
and hit the bag;
you'll feel so much better.
- What's the difference, though?
They're both, like,
active things.
- Well, you're not doing
something spontaneous
and acting on impulse.
[growls]
It's premeditated.
You know you're gonna go, "Okay,
I'm gonna pack my bag,
"I'm gonna go to the gym,
I'll be releasing endorphins."
You'll feel more relaxed
and you'll be able to assess
the bank manager who's been
irritating you
for the last hour.
- Can I--can I try hitting
some things?
- Definitely.
You can try hitting me.
- Can I really?
- Yes.
Are you gonna hit back?
- I will--
I will let you know I'm there.
- Okay.
[dramatic music]
Awesome.
Do I look scary?
- [laughs]
- Oh, yeah.
Is Rhino correct that
violent acts of rage
won't calm you down?
But the controlled aggression
used in boxing
will actually relax you?
♪ ♪
I guess I'm about to find out.
[bell dings]
♪ ♪
- Yes, like that.
No, no.
- [groaning]
- No.
Come on.
- Well done!
Good work.
- I came out of the fight
having learned two things.
One, I'm a wimp.
And two, Rhino was right;
when physical violence
is channeled
in an organized sport
like boxing,
it can actually reduce feelings
of aggression.
I had this weird combination
of feelings.
As tired as I am...
- Yep.
- I'm very amped up.
- So now you feel it.
- Yeah.
I don't feel aggressive.
- You feel relaxed?
- I wouldn't say
I'm relaxed here;
I would just say
I'm clearer here,
and I feel more in control.
- Eye of the tiger, Rock.
- Yeah, well, maybe it's the eye
of the kitten,
who is in a bad mood,
but, man, that was great.
♪ ♪
It's time for the final part of
our anger room demonstration.
All of our subjects
will be taking part
in what they think
is a reflex test
against their opponent Clint.
In reality, of course,
there is no Client,
and what we're really
looking at
is the Catharsis Theory.
Have our subjects' levels
of anger been affected
according to whether
they committed
violent acts of destruction.
Or not.
Stage three is going to be
testing
how your reflexes are working
at this very moment.
Okay?
So this right here is
a static electricity generator
that is going to provide
a little bit of a shock.
We're putting one on Clint
as well,
and he's in another room,
but you both have
the same setup.
Once our subjects are fitted
with the shock bracelet,
they're introduced to
the test's control panel.
- [chuckles]
Look at this.
- Yeah, it's very simplified,
but that really helps keep
the variables low.
So both you and Clint will be
competing in a bit of a game.
The yellow light is going to
come on at some point,
and as soon as you see it
come on,
hit that orange button.
And if you hit this button
before Clint does,
you'll see the green light
come on.
And that will mean that you won.
And Clint needs to receive
a small shock, okay?
And you can set this to a level
of your choosing.
- So--okay.
Light goes on,
if I hit this,
the green one comes and then
I'm allowed
to work this contraption.
- Correct.
- Which controls how
high the voltage and for how
long the voltage.
- Correct.
- Okay.
- If however, Clint pushes
the button before you do,
the red light will come on,
indicating--
- My red light and I'm about
to get it.
- That you'll get a shock, yeah.
Correct.
We'll get a sense of our
subjects' level of anger
by how they respond to the
chance to administer pain
to Clint.
Remember, this subject just sat
in the anger room passively.
- Did I get him?
Oh, all right.
- The green light means
our subject wins.
How hard will he shock Clint?
- I'm gonna give you a little
low one, buddy.
[buzzing]
There you go.
Just a kiss.
Ah, got me.
- The red light means
Clint won.
How will our subject respond
to getting shocked?
[static buzz]
- Ah!
[laughs]
You son of a bitch.
[chuckles]
- Not only does this subject
not seem angry, he's actually
enjoying the game.
- All right.
[buzzing]
How about that?
I'm not gonna harm you, man.
Gave ya a little low one.
- He actually seems
relatively calm.
Will our other passive subject
follow suit?
[static buzz]
Clint gave her a painful shock.
Let's see how strongly
she retaliates.
[buzzing]
Even after getting a shock
from Clint,
this subject is still hesitant
to give him a shock in return.
[over PA]
Okay, Clint and Drea,
this is just a reminder
that you are--
you are allowed to change
that dial
to what you think would be
appropriate.
- Yeah, I just don't want to,
like, hurt him or anything.
I'm just gonna keep it at low.
- So the angry subjects
who sat passively
seemed to have calmed down.
Now it's time to check on the
subjects who acted violently
in the anger room.
Did letting out all of
that aggression
relieve their anger?
[over PA]
The experiment will begin now.
[buzzing]
- Take it, take it, take it.
- Kashona.
That's--that's fine.
What level is your dial at?
- Um...
Low.
[buzzing]
- He cranked that all the way up
and he's laying on that button.
This subject was one of
the most aggressive people
in the anger room,
but that doesn't seem to have
calmed him down.
[buzzing]
- Among our subjects,
it seems that those
who physically vented
their anger are still
pretty angry
compared to that subjects
who sat quietly.
- So at least in this case,
catharsis therapy
was not effective.
In fact, in some cases,
the subject seems even angrier.
- Ow! [bleep]
You know what?
That's too hard.
You [bleep] dick!
Why don't you come in here and
[bleep] talk to me in person?
- Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
- We're all familiar with
the concept of rubbernecking.
It's hard to look away from
a car crash.
- Oh, my God.
- But why?
There are surely a myriad
of reasons,
but one may be that at
a primitive level,
witnessing danger allows us
to learn and prepare for it.
Activities where danger
and destruction are likely
are exciting.
Starting in our childhood,
physical aggression
is encouraged,
even in games.
Take a piñata for example.
As a special birthday treat,
we are told to beat up
an effigy with a baseball bat.
And when we hit it hard enough,
we are rewarded with candy.
What parts of a child's urge
to destroy are innate
versus learned?
Well, there is a groundbreaking
experiment
that shed light on this.
In 1961, Albert Bandura
conducted a famous
and controversial study
called the Bobo Doll Experiment.
He had adults act violently
to an inflatable clown doll
in the presence of children.
Then left the children alone
with the same doll
to see if they would mimic
the destructive behavior
they'd observed.
Disturbingly, the children
did indeed copy the adults,
and lashed out at the doll,
often getting very creative
with their aggression
and destruction.
Aggression comes in many
unexpected forms.
Why is it so hard to resist
popping bubbles in bubble wrap,
for instance?
Do we like the sound?
The destruction?
Or both?
It's like we're naturally drawn
to destroying
these harmless plastic bubbles
of air.
Destructive tendencies seem
to be so engrained in us
that we even respond
to positive stimulation
with urges to destroy.
One of the strangest things
about destruction
is how people want to hug things
to death,
especially things that are
extremely cute,
like a puppy.
We don't know exactly why
this is,
but there is a study
that demonstrates the effect
by using bubble wrap
and our desire
to pop these bubbles.
[popping]
Oh, yeah.
[dramatic music]
Can sweet adorable stimuli
really insight
aggressive behavior?
We're about to find out.
- Thank you for participating
in our focus test.
- No problem.
- Please make yourself
comfortable.
- We've recruited subjects
who think
they're taking part
in a motor skills test.
- Are you familiar with
this product?
- Yes.
- Have you popped the bubbles
in bubble wrap before?
- Yes.
- But really what we're testing
is their aggressive response
to cute stimuli.
- So you will be viewing
a montage of images.
Please pop bubbles
in the bubble wrap.
You may pop as many or as few
as you like.
Just be sure to start
when the images begin
and stop when the images end.
- Popping bubbles is like
squeezing a stress ball.
It's a great way
to express aggression.
The question is, will
the subjects pop more bubbles
when watching neutral images
or cute ones?
♪ ♪
First we showed our subjects
these basic landscapes,
which are not designed to
elicit an emotional response.
[pop]
And we tallied the total number
of bubbles popped.
♪ ♪
[pop]
- Okay, great.
I'll take those.
All right, we're gonna do
part two,
where you'll be viewing
another set of images.
- Okay.
- We also showed them images
of...
puppies.
[playful piano music]
♪ ♪
Oh, look at that one!
Don't you just want to hug it
and squeeze it to--
well, okay, you get the point.
♪ ♪
To keep things even,
half of the subjects viewed
the landscapes first
and half viewed the puppies
first.
But either way, they seemed
to pop a lot more bubbles
while watching the puppies.
Except for this guy.
[pop]
♪ ♪
So-called cute aggression
is a universal
psychological phenomenon.
Researchers believe
the brain's response
to both cuteness and aggression
results in the release
of dopamine
implicated in the reward
and pleasure,
but if we are unable to
physically touch cute stimuli,
the desire to do so
can be regulated
by substituting aggressive
physical behavior.
Will our results reflect
this theory?
♪ ♪
[laughs]
- How did you feel
about the images that you saw?
- They were cool.
- How did you feel about
the puppies?
- I love them.
- They were very tiny
and adorable.
And I wanted to hug them.
- And how did you feel about
popping the bubble wrap?
- I felt like I wanted to
play with the dogs or--
I wanted to play with the bubble
wrap with the dogs.
- In our simple test, our
subjects popped an average
of 33% more bubbles while
watching cute puppies,
as opposed to
boring landscapes.
- So was the bubble wrap
a stand-in for the puppies?
- I guess so.
- In fact, the majority
of our subjects
popped more bubbles
while watching puppies.
But not this guy.
Remember him?
- So how did you feel about
seeing the dog pictures?
- Um, I've always been more
of a cat person.
- It seems sometimes cuteness
is a matter of perspective.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
Our relationship with
destruction is not a simple one.
It can release endorphins
and relax our minds.
It can amp us up and make us
even more aggressive.
It can even help us regulate
our emotional reactions
to cute things.
Destruction can be useful,
it can be dangerous,
and it can be a lot of fun.
♪ ♪
And as always,
thanks for watching.
[electronic music]
♪ ♪